die Stärke einer Landeswährung hängt von
der Stärke der Landwirtschaft ab Amerika
hat mit Abstand die stärkste Wirtschaft
der Welt
folglich habe ich den Finanzminister
angewiesen die nötigen Schritte zu
ergreifen um den Dollar vor Spekulanten
zu schützen
Minister Kanal wurde angewiesen
vorübergehend die eintauschbarkeit des
Dollars in Gold oder andere Reserve
Werte aufzuheben sofern die Mengen und
Bedingungen nicht der finanziellen
Stabilität und den Interessen der
Vereinigten Staaten die nicht sind
der 15 August 1971 wird noch für viele
Generationen ein entscheidendes Ereignis
der Wirtschaftsgeschichte sein selbst in
hunderten von Jahren wird man sich noch
daran erinnern
[Musik]
das auch heute geht die Sonne auf die
schon millionenfach zuvor Pendler wachen
auf und fahren ins Büro um ihr Tagwerk
zu verrichten
Landwirte kümmern sich um die Ernte und
Bauarbeiter errichten neue Infrastruktur
es ist ein Tag wie jeder andere oder
nicht
2008 erlebte die Welt eines der größten
wirtschaftsbeben aller Zeiten
weltweit brachen die Märkte ein und
Finanzinstitutionen die einst als
unangreifbarkeiten drohten in sich
zusammen zu fallen
Regierungen reagierten schnell und
beschlossen rettungs- und
Konjunkturpakete um die Weltwirtschaft
über Wasser zu halten er mit Erfolg die
globale Wirtschaft erholte sich viel
schneller als die meisten erwarteten und
alles war wieder wie zuvor und doch
stimmt etwas nicht ganz
die Unruhe in der Bevölkerung nimmt zu
in der Finanzwelt wenn nicht gar in
allen Bereichen des modernen Lebens tun
sich Risse auf
[Musik]
viele haben Angst wenn man die Menschen
auf der Straße fragt wissen sie zwar
nicht was genau los ist aber sie spüren
das etwas nicht stimmt
die Regierung macht Verluste in
Millionenhöhe warum wächst die
Wirtschaft nicht wieder die Regierung
gibt fast 3,7 Millionen Dollar aus warum
habe ich keine Arbeit warum liegt die
Arbeitslosigkeit bei 9%, wenn nicht
sogar höher
viele in der heutigen Welt sind
verunsichert und besorgt dass etwas
Schreckliches bevorstehen könnte es
heißt die Weltfinanzkrise von vor ein
paar Jahren sei überwunden was aber wenn
die Krise nicht einfach nur die Ursache
unserer Angst war sondern Symptom eines
viel tiefer greifenden problems
in Brandenburg treffen die Delegierten
aus 44 Ländern der Alliierten zur
Eröffnung der un-finanzkonferenz ein
die Geschichte beginnt 1944 am Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs trafen sich die
Alliierten in Brandenburgs New Hampshire
um ein neues Finanzsystem zu etablieren
und die Welt in der Nachkriegszeit zu
stabilisieren da man ein goldenes
Zeitalter für die USA erwartete wurde
der US-Dollar zur Leitwährung ernannt
-System wurde nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
bei der Konferenz in Brandenburger
schaffen
anstatt Gold als Tauschmedium zwischen
Ländern zu verwenden wie es beim vorigen
Goldstandard der Fall war entschied man
sich den Dollar zu verwenden denn der
war damals so gut wie Gold
in diesem neuen System wurde für jede
Landeswährung ein fester Wechselkurs zum
Dollar bestimmt der Dollar war mit einem
festen Preis von 35 Dollar pro Unze an
Gold gebunden somit konnten alle Länder
der Welt ihre Währung in Dollar und
diese dann in Gold umwandeln
dadurch waren letztlich in diesem System
alle Währungen durch Gold gedeckt
um das physische Gold nicht über den
Globus verschicken zu müssen wurde das
Gold in das andere Länder ihre Währungen
eintauschten sicher in den USA verwahrt
unter dem breitenwood-system könnten
andere Länder und Zentralbanken ihre
Währungen und Dollar in Gold umtauschen
dann fingen die Haushaltsdefizite an das
great society-programm von Linden
Johnson der Krieg in Vietnam plötzlich
waren wir Minus und die anderen Länder
gaben ihre Dollar ab und wollten Gold
zuerst Frankreich dann immer mehr
in Anbetracht der wachsenden Ausgaben
befürchteten andere Länder die USA
könnten mehr Geld ausgeben als ihre
Goldreserven abdecken
sie tauschten ihre Dollar in Gold um und
verlangten physische goldlieferungen da
sie vermuteten es würden mehr Dollar
gedruckt als Gold vorhanden war
um die Abwanderung des Goldes aus den
us-dressuren zu unterbinden ließ
Präsident nix in den Umtausch in Gold
aussetzen
folglich habe ich den Finanzminister
angewiesen die nötigen Schritte zu
ergreifen um den Dollar vor Spekulanten
zu schützen
Minister Cornely wurde angewiesen
vorübergehend die eintauschbarkeit des
Dollars in Gold oder andere reservewerte
aufzuheben
alle Probleme unseres aktuellen
Finanzsystems sind direkte Folgen der
Entscheidung vom 15 August 1971 die
feste Verbindung zu Gold aufzugeben
goldzwang Regierungen zur Disziplin und
zur Mäßigung ihrer Ausgaben
hatte man im alten System ein
Haushaltsdefizit wurde so lange Gold
ausgeführt bis das Gleichgewicht wieder
hergestellt war
ohne die Abdeckung durch Gold sind
starten nun dauerhaft im Defizit die USA
zum Beispiel hatten seit 1971 keinen
Haushaltsüberschuss mehr seit wir vom
Goldstandard weg sind hatten wir
durchgehen Konjunktur Defizite in guten
wie in schlechten Zeiten
1971 den Goldstandard auf angeblich nur
vorübergehend aber wir warten noch immer
auf die wieder Einführung
wir machten in den 60ern massive
verluste-wirtschaft bei der die
Regierung zum einen Krieg in Vietnam
führte und zum anderen bemannte
Mondmissionen und das raumfahrprogramm
finanzierte mussten wir mehr Geld
drucken als unsere Goldreserven zuließen
viele unserer ausländischen Kreditgeber
sahen das und verlangten Gold anstatt
der Banknoten der Federal Reserve weil
sie spürten das Washington nicht genug
Gold haben würde und das wertversprechen
des Dollars einzuhalten
indem er die Verbindung zum Gold kappte
der schuf Präsident Nixen ein System in
dem alle Währungen durch nichts gedeckt
waren man spricht hierbei von
fiatwährungen
Fiat Währungen sind durch nichts außer
Versprechen von Regierungen gedeckt
Fiat kommt aus dem Lateinischen es ist
also Geld das durch Zwang im Umlauf ist
wenn die Menschen der Währung Vertrauen
und die Regierung genug Macht hat bleibt
die Währung eine Weile lang im Umlauf
bis die Menschen das Vertrauen wieder
verlieren
kein Land der Welt verwendet aktuell
tatsächliches Geld wir alle nutzen
Währungen irgendwann werden wir alle den
Unterschied erkennen
Manni
Geld ist ein Austausch Medium es war
dabei immer etwas das von sich aus Wert
hatte bis zur Moderne
Politiker sagen wir brauchen nichts
Wertvolles mehr wir brauchen nur
politische Entscheidungen wir sagen
einfach diese Stück Papier wäre Geld
jetzt hat Geld eine neue Eigenschaft
aber grundsätzlich gilt das gleiche
Konzept das niemand anzuzweifeln wagt
nämlich das Regierungen das Recht haben
etwas an sich wertloses zu Geld zu
erklären und dass man das zu akzeptieren
habe das ist ein Problem und es zerstört
auch heute noch die Weltwirtschaft
oder Währungen nicht mehr durch echte
Werte gedeckt sind bemisst sich ihr Wert
nur noch im Verhältnis zueinander
Länder mit schwachen Währungen können
Produkte günstig herstellen also
entwerten sie ihre Währungen gezielt um
als Handelspartner attraktiver zu werden
jede Papierwährung vergleicht sich mit
dem Dollar
sinkt der Dollar reagieren die
Zentralbanken anderer Länder und
schreiten auf dem Währungsmarkt ein
damit die Auswirkungen ihre Wirtschaft
nicht beeinträchtigen
was ist ein ponsi System ein
ponsi-system ist ein betrügerisches
investment-angebot das Investoren große
Gewinne bei keinem oder geringem Risiko
verspricht klingt so gut um wahr zu sein
stimmt bei seriösen investmentmodellen
wird das Geld zur Wertschöpfung in
risikoarme Anlagewerte die Aktien oder
Immobilienportfolios investiert mit der
Zeit generiert dies genug Einkommen um
die Investition zuzüglich eines profits
zurückzuzahlen ein ponsi System
verspricht jedoch gewaltige Gewinne in
kürzester Zeit wie funktioniert das
anstatt das Geld sinnvoll zu investieren
werden bei einem ponsi System einfach
mehr Investoren gewonnen um die vorigen
Investoren auszuzahlen ähm da den neuen
Investoren auch große Gewinne
versprochen wurden muss anschließend
eine noch größere Gruppe gefunden werden
um sie zu bezahlen während die
Initiatoren einen Teil des Geldes jeder
Gruppe für sich behalten
da das ponti-system selbst keinen Wert
generiert Wissen kontinuierlich immer
größere Investorengruppen hinzugezogen
werden damit es weiter funktioniert
irgendwann findet man keine neuen
Investoren mehr oder eine große Anzahl
der bisherigen Investoren will sich
zeitgleich auszahlen lassen wodurch das
System zusammenbricht
zu dem Zeitpunkt haben die Initiatoren
gewaltige Beträge für sich beiseite
geschafft und die Investoren haben keine
Gewinne sondern Pech gehabt
ohne feste Verbindung zum Gold konnte
die us-staatskasse beliebig viel Geld
leihen und ausgeben
braucht die US-Regierung Geld leiht sie
es sich von der US-Notenbank die
Notenbank druckt die für das Darlehen
erforderlichen Banknoten und bekommt von
der Staatskasse einen Schuldschein
die Schuldscheine nennt man
Staatsanleihen
mit dem Geld dieser Darlehen oder
Anleihen bezahlt die US-Regierung ihre
Rechnungen und Verpflichtungen
zeitgleich versteigern die
us-staatskasse und die Notenbank diese
Anleihen gemeinsam bei Auktionen wo
ausländische Zentralbanken Rentenfonds
und auch Einzelpersonen diese
US-Staatsanleihen kaufen warum auch
nicht der US-Regierung Geld zu leihen
war seit jeher eine sichere Investition
wenn die darlinie doch für Rechnungen
und die Auszahlung frühere Anleihen
genutzt werden woher bekommt die
Regierung das Geld um die aktuellen
Anleihen mit Zinsen zurückzuzahlen ist
die Investition in Anleihen der
US-Regierung letztlich Teil eines
gewaltigen ponsi-systems
das System der US-Notenbank ist ein
panzersystem ganz ohne Zweifel
sie geben vor der Regierung Geld zu
leihen und die Regierung sagt zu das
Geld mit Zinsen zurückzuzahlen
das Geld wird tatsächlich erst für genau
diesen Zweck erschaffen und der
Regierung gegeben vorher existierte es
gar nicht Zentralbanken er Fitness aus
dem Nichts mit ein paar computer-clicks
erschaffen Sie eine Billion Dollar die
die Staatskasse der Regierung nun
ausgeben kann so einfach entsteht das
Geld die US-Regierung ist nun aber
verpflichtet das Geld mit Zinsen
zurückzuzahlen die Zinsen darf man nicht
vergessen
wenn sie es zurückzahlen müssen können
sie das nicht schon gar nicht mit Zinsen
also leihen Sie sich einfach noch mehr
Geld um die ursprünglichen Kredite mit
Zinsen zu bezahlen
und der Schuldenberg wächst und wächst
und wächst
im aktuellen Währungssystem entsteht
unser Geld dadurch dass wir es uns
leihen und versprechen es mit Zinsen
zurückzubezahlen wenn der erste und
einzige Dollar der Welt dadurch entsteht
dass man ihn sich Leid und dann mit
einem Dollar Zinsen zurückzahlen will
woher kommt der zweite Dollar man muss
ihn natürlich leiden es ist ein
ponsi-system da man die Schulden nie
abbezahlen kann und immer mehr anhäufen
muss
seit 1971 haben die USA ein
Handelsdefizit im Verhältnis zu übrigen
Welt wir kaufen also viel mehr Produkte
von ihnen als sie insgesamt von uns
kaufen
Japan und Korea verkaufen uns Autos und
Elektroartikel der neuosten verkauft uns
Öl China verkauft uns gefühlt das ganze
Supermarkt Angebot
die USA zahlen dafür in US-Dollar und
alles in zufrieden aber würden die
Länder diese Dollar Gewinne in ihre
eigenen Währungen konvertieren würden
diese an Wert gewinnen und das Land
würde als Handelspartner weniger
attraktiv
stattdessen investieren diese Länder
ihre Dollar Gewinne in US-Staatsanleihen
die Länder der Welt verkaufen ihre Waren
an die USA im Austausch für US-Dollar
die von der US-Notenbank gegen
Schuldscheine geliehen wurden
dann allein die Länder den USA ihre
Dollar Gewinne zurück indem sie
ihrerseits Schuldschein erwerben
das Geld dieser Darlehen wird zur
Begleichung von Rechnungen und zur
Auszahlung früherer Kredite verwendet
dafür müssen aber immer größere Kredite
aufgenommen werden um die gelenenbeträge
mit Zinsen zurückzuzahlen
der alte Darlehen durch neue größere
Darlehen zurückgezahlt werden wirkt es
als würde die ganze Welt ihr Geld in ein
ponsi-system epischen Ausmaßes
investieren
wenn bei diesem Geschäft der
geldherstellung für Regierungen hier und
überall auf der Welt nicht mehr und mehr
Geld generiert würde welche das ganze in
sich zusammen
denn es entschließlich die neuen
Schulden mit denen die alten Schulden
beglichen werden
es ist ein ganz klassisches panzersystem
damit die US-Wirtschaft funktioniert
müssen wir uns mehr und mehr Geld von
anderen Ländern leihen je mehr Sie uns
heute leihen desto mehr müssen Sie uns
in Zukunft bleiben hören sie irgendwann
auf damit bricht alles zusammen und wir
können sie nicht zurück bezahlen
jeden Freitagabend vergleicht Julia die
Preise der lokalen Supermärkte für ihren
Samstagmorgen Einkauf
es gibt fünf Märkte in den Blocks um
unser Haus und Julia kauft alles dort wo
die Preise am niedrigsten und die
Qualität am höchsten ist
ein Schokoriegel kostete mal einen
Viertel Dollar eine Tankfüllung 5 Dollar
eine sechsköpfige Familie Arzt für 35
Dollar pro Woche was ist seit dem
Geschehen ohne greifbare Grundlage für
Währungen konnten Regierungen so viel
Geld drucken wie sie wollten
das hat den Wert unserer Währung nach
und nach untergraben
die Erschaffung all dieses Geldes
verringert den Wert der bestehenden
Dollar immer mehr wodurch die Kaufkraft
immer weiter senkt
eine Gallone Benzin kostete mal 31 Cent
jetzt sind es etwa 5 Dollar
Verbraucher lebt Inflation als
verringerte Kaufkraft dadurch sinkt sein
Lebensstandard wenn er nicht mit der
Inflationsrate Schritt halten kann
in vielen Bereichen ist der
Lebensstandard in Amerika heute
schlechter nehmen wir meine Großeltern
als Beispiel meine Großmutter musste nie
arbeiten obwohl mein Großvater nur
Schreiner war und sie acht Kinder hatten
könnt ihr ein Schreiner ein Arbeiter im
Handwerk ohne Highschool Abschluss heute
eine Frau und acht Kinder finanzieren
keine Chance
da die Inflation schneller stieg als das
Einkommen musste der Lebensstandard mit
immer drastischeren Maßnahmen erhalten
werden
jeden Tag beginnt die Arbeit der Familie
von Neuem
bevor wir den Dollar vom Gold trenten
den üblicherweise der Mann arbeiten und
die Frau kümmerte sich um Haus und
Familie
in den 70ern arbeitete die Frau dann
aufgrund der Inflation auch man braucht
ja also zwei Einkommen um die gleichen
Waren und Dienstleistungen zu bezahlen
in den 90ern hörten wir auf zu sparen
die Sparquote viel nahezu auf null man
musste das Geld ausgeben um die gleichen
waren und Dienste zu kaufen und konnte
nicht sparen dann in den 2000ern
die Frau arbeitete schon
Ersparnisse waren auf Null also niemand
Geld
wir brauchten also erst zwei Einkommen
mussten aufhören zu sparen und zuletzt
Geld leihen und mit der Inflation
Schritt zu halten
der Durchschnittsverbraucher sieht sich
nun gezwungen Geld zu leihen und
verschuldet sich dadurch erheblich
zuerst diente dies der Aufrechterhaltung
eines gehobenen Lebensstandards doch
mittlerweile ist es allein für das
Überleben erforderlich bei es scheint
als würden Regierungen indem sie mehr
und mehr Geld drucken und ihre Währung
entwerten ihrem Volk eine verdeckte
Zusatzsteuer auferlegen
Zentralbanken behaupten zwei oder drei
Prozent Inflation wären etwas Gutes
erstrebenswert sogar es sind aber
Steuern wieso sind zwei oder drei
Prozent Inflation besser für das Land
als keine Inflation
es heißt dann immer dass er besser als
Deflation und das den Menschen das
Gefühl gefällt ihr Einkommen würde um
ein paar Prozent steigen das wäre doch
etwas Gutes
tatsächlich wird Ihnen jedoch Geld
gestohlen und ihr effektives Einkommen
singt
wir erleben derzeit Inflation angeblich
steigt der VPI um zwei oder drei Prozent
aber es fällt doch jedem auf dass die
Inflation viel größer ist womöglich
sogar zweistellig
die Kaufkraft des Durchschnittsbürgers
schrumpft dramatisch
um dies zu verbergen verzerren
Regierungen jedoch die Daten ihrer
Berichte damit die Inflation viel
kleiner wirkt als sie tatsächlich ist
es gibt diese befremdliche
Unterscheidung zwischen Kerninflation
und Gesamtinflation die viele nicht
verstehen die Kerninflation ist diese
Zielwert von 2%. nicht weiter wichtig
die Gesamtinflation berücksichtigt auch
Dinge wie Energiepreise plötzliche
Steuererhöhungen und dergleichen die
Inflationsrate ist verzerrt man nutzt
allerlei Ausflüchte um sie geringer
erscheinen zu lassen als sie ist
würde die Regierung den VPI genauso
berechnen wie damals unter Präsident
Carter in den späten 70ern werde die
Inflationsrate in den USA heute 9 oder
10 %. so sehr wird die Währung entfernt
der
grund dafür sind die vielen
inflationsbereinigten Verpflichtungen
der US-Regierung so sind zum Beispiel
Hilfszahlungen im Sozialsystem Inflation
bereinigt und an diese angepasst wenn
Sie die Inflationsrate in den
offiziellen Statistiken klein halten
müssen sie weniger zahlen unter
Staatsdefizit singt
die blühende Metropole tolido ist eines
der größten Zentren für die
Glasverarbeitung
in ohious 5 größter Stadt Akron geht es
hingegen primär um
[Musik]
gummiherstellungshauptstadt des Landes
sogar der Welt steht für Gummi in einer
Welt in der Währungen nur in Relation
zueinander bewertet werden kann können
Staaten den Wert ihrer Währung künstlich
verringern und ihre Industrie so einen
Wettbewerbsvorteil verschaffen ein Land
mit einer schwachen Währung kann
Produkte billiger herstellen und so für
die internationale Verlagerung ganze
Industriezweige sorgen dies ließ sich
zahllose Male in Städten auf der ganzen
Welt beobachten einige davon haben sich
immer noch nicht vom Verlust ihrer
Industrie erholt
die Menschen sind verzweifelt sie haben
studiert haben keine Arbeit finden keine
Arbeit müssen Studentenkredite bezahlen
haben erhöhte Lebenshaltungskosten die
Fett sagt es gebe keine Inflation aber
man sieht doch wie die Preise für Eier
Milch und Fleisch im Laden steigen die
Spritpreise an der Tankstelle steigen
auch man versteht nicht wie sehr der
einzelne betroffen ist
darum sind sie frustriert denn es wird
einem nirgendwo beigebracht das Geld zu
drucken ohne dass es gedeckt ist die
Währung entwertet und all diese
Nebenwirkungen hervorruft die wir
beobachten
steigende inflationskosten Korruption
Günstlingswirtschaft all das hat in den
letzten Jahren Schlagzeilen gemacht
Protestbewegungen sind ein interessantes
Phänomen viele Menschen sind
fürchterlich wütend auf die Wallstreet
auf das was mit ihrer Kaufkraft
geschieht sie sind wütend darüber dass
sie in den Nachrichten erfahren die
Manager dieser Banken bekämen Boni in
Millionenhöhe während sie gleichzeitig
dem Steuerzahler im Rahmen der
Bankenrettung auf der Tasche liegen
während das macht sie wütend
leider demonstrieren die Menschen zwar
gegen die Wirtschaftskrise fordern aber
gleichzeitig mehr Sozialhilfe staatliche
Krankenversicherungen mehr staatliche
Kontrolle und Regulierung das mehr Geld
erschaffen und in die Gesellschaft
gesteckt werden soll
und bemerken dabei jedoch nicht dass
diese Dinge die wahre Ursache sind warum
sie wütend auf die Straße gehen
während der einzelne nur mit Mühe über
die Runden kommt erzählt man uns es sei
eine normale Rezession
warum aber fühlt sich diese Krise dann
anders an als vorangegangen der
Rezessionen
das ist alles andere als normal es ist
viel eher das Ende wir erleben den
Todeskampf unseres 40-jährigen
Experiments mit Fiat Währungen welches
in einem absoluten Fehlschlag endet in
Amerika ebenso wie überall auf der Welt
bis 2008 liegen wir uns mehr und mehr
Geld um unseren Lebensstandard zu
erhalten
haben wir nun das Maximum erreicht und
können keine weiteren Schulden aufnehmen
heute findet in allen
Gesellschaftsschichten ein Schuldenabbau
statt die Verbraucher sind am Limit
jedes Mal wenn wir den Zyklus von
Höhenflug und Pleite durchlaufen haben
wurde mit der Pleite die nächste
Inflation losgetreten um die Wirtschaft
anzukurbeln wodurch jedes Mal mehr und
mehr Schulden angehäuft wurden
jetzt ist der Punkt erreicht an dem wir
keine Schulden mehr machen können
Banken gewähren Kredite nicht mehr so
leichtfertig wie zuvor viele Bürger sind
damit beschäftigt alte Schulden
abzubezahlen anstatt neue Schulden
aufzunehmen das ist zum einen vorsichtig
und vernünftig zum anderen eine
Bedrohung für die Weltwirtschaft als
gewaltiges ponsi-system ist die
Weltwirtschaft für ihren Fortbestand
darauf angewiesen dass immer mehr und
immer größere Schulden angehäuft werden
wenn wir nicht über unsere Verhältnisse
leben und versuchen mit dem Geld dass
wir haben auszukommen bricht die
währungsversorgung durch die Zinsen in
sich zusammen
darum müssen wir weiterhin jeden Monat
mehr Dollar erschaffen und uns leihen
als wir an Schulden abbauen können
so wie das System aktuell aufgestellt
ist muss die Geldversorgung konstant
ausgeweitet werden damit das System
nicht untergeht
Politiker und Kommentatoren predigen ein
gemäßigtes Leben und die Begleichung der
Schulden dadurch würde aber die
Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen sie würde
regelrecht verschwinden
alle Politiker sind in der Zwickmühle
wenn sie nicht zur Rettung eilen bricht
über Nacht alles zusammen und das will
niemand so lange an der Macht ist darum
wollen alle die Verantwortung
weitergeben und lassen den Kelch quasi
an sich vorüberziehen
es ist aber das Ende der Fahnenstange
erreicht wir können den Kelch an
niemanden mehr weitergeben und müssen
selbst damit fertig werden was mit jedem
Mal als er weitergegeben wurde
schwieriger wurde
es ist ein großes Problem geworden
die Finanzkrise von 2008 mag das erste
Vorzeichen vom Ende des ponti-systems
gewesen sein doch Regierungen auf der
ganzen Welt machten keine Anstalten es
einfach untergehen zu lassen also
verzögerten sie das Unvermeidliche durch
die Rettung maroder Finanzinstitutionen
sie kauften faule Hypotheken und nahmen
im Namen des Volkes Schulden auf
2009 und 2010 wurde die Krise einfach
überbrückt indem man Banken rettete und
stetig neues Geld druckte und ins System
Punkte man sollte nicht vergessen dass
Regierungen auf kurze Sicht Ergebnisse
einfach erzwingen können langfristig
wurden die Probleme aber nicht gelöst
die Schulden sind noch da die Banken
sind noch immer insolvent und bessern
sich nicht die Wirtschaft stagniert
nichts wurde gelöst
indem sie sich immer wieder frei kaufen
Geld drucken das System damit überfluten
und die Kaufkraft verwässern lösen Sie
das Problem nicht sie schieben es nur
ein wenig auf und machen es noch
schlimmer
machen wir nun also einfach so weiter
und drucken mehr Geld die Bilanz der
fettwuchs schon von 800 Milliarden auf 3
Billionen sollen es jetzt 6 Billionen
werden kommt nach dem 800 Milliarden
Konjunkturpaket eins mit zwei Billionen
das könnte man schon machen aber so
würde die Währung mangels Vertrauen
womöglich einbrechen
der offene Geldhahn der US-Notenbank
stützt die Wirtschaft kurzfristig
durchaus doch was sind die Folgen wenn
man in diesem Maßstab einfach Geld
druckt
ich erwarte das der Wert des Dollars
sehr schnell einbrechen wird innerhalb
weniger Tage ob nun um 20 30 oder 40
Prozent viele flüchten sich zur
Sicherheit in den Dollar was wenn Sie
nun merken dass es hier gar keine
Sicherheit gibt und dass sie aus dem
Dollar fliehen müssen der aktuell von
der Angst profitiert was wenn die
Menschen um den Dollar fürchten
zusätzlich zur gewaltigen Inflation
besteht auch das Risiko dass die
US-Notenbank indem sie weiterhin
leichtfertig Geld druckt das globale
Vertrauen in den US-Dollar erschüttern
könnte
eine Währungskrise halte ich für sehr
wahrscheinlich was genau sie wann
verursachen wird ist schwer
vorherzusagen vielleicht kommt sie
überraschend durch eine Naturkatastrophe
einen politischen Schock oder einfach
durch Vertrauensverlust
da würde schon eine einfache Auktion des
Finanzministeriums reichen die mangels
Käufern scheitert wodurch die Zinsen
steigen werden
dann reagieren die großen Hedgefonds und
stoßen ihre Dollar ab
gefolgt von ausländischen Zentralbanken
die aus dem Dollar flüchten und schon
ist es passiert
wie bei jedem ponsi-system erkennen die
Teilnehmer irgendwann wie der Hase läuft
und wollen aussteigen wodurch alles in
sich zusammenfällt wenn private und
freiwillige Teilnehmer also private
Investoren und ausländische
Zentralbanken nicht mehr weiter kaufen
kann die Notenbank einschreiten und die
Forderungen derer die aus dem
ponsi-system Aussteigen wollen erfüllen
wenn die US-Notenbank dann aber der
einzige verbleibende Käufer ist ist das
Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht und die
Hyperinflation beginnt
Inflation ist ein derart schneller
Anstieg der Inflationsrate dass die
Menschen das Vertrauen in die Währung
verlieren was dann auch zur
währungsflucht führt
galoppierende Inflation im besiegten
Deutschland
[Musik]
die Mark ist so wertlos geworden dass
man sie als Tapete oder zum Anheizen des
Ofens verwendet
die Regierung sieht sich also gezwungen
so viel Geld auszugeben und zu leihen
dass der Markt irgendwann nicht mehr
gewillt ist entsprechende Mengen zu
verleihen dann schreitet die Zentralbank
ein und verwandelt die Schulden in neue
Währung
die große Frage ist wobei ich die
Antwort selbst nicht kenne bei wie viel
Inflation 5 10 15 20 Prozent beginnt die
Panik wenn es soweit ist werden aber
sicherlich alle in Panik verfallen
infolge einer Hyperinflation steigen die
Preise für Waren und Dienstleistungen
rapide wodurch die Menschen sich ihrer
Währung noch schneller entledigen
dann fangen die Leute an Waren zu kaufen
nur um ihr Papiergeld loszuwerden das
treibt die Nachfrage nach Papiergeld
paradoxerweise noch weiter an weil man
ja damit einkaufen will
somit singt der Wert des papiergels noch
bevor es in Umlauf kommt
im Alltag wird man nach Kräften
greifbare Dinge bekommen wollen
statt einer Dose Thunfisch kauft man
dann zwei man weiß ja dass die gleiche
Dose morgen oder vielleicht sogar schon
später am gleichen Tag mehr kosten wird
man hortet alles was irgendwie greifbar
ist
das wird mit einem großen
wirtschaftlichen Leid einhergehen
viele Ruheständler in Amerika werden
sich Arbeit suchen müssen weil ihre
Altersvorsorge sich plötzlich in Luft
aufgelöst hat
sie haben sich auf einen nationales
ponsi-system in bester burning mad of
Manier verlassen auch Immobilien werden
verfallen da die Menschen zuerst ihre
unmittelbaren Bedürfnisse decken müssen
und kein Geld für Reparaturen und
Instandhaltungen haben werden wenn
Vermieter keine Miete mehr bezahlt
bekommen wie sollen sie die Immobilien
erhalten und Steuern zahlen
die ganze Wirtschaft wird von der Last
der Inflation erdrückt werden
die erste Reaktion der Notenbank wird
natürlich sein noch mehr Inflation zu
verursachen indem sie die Wirtschaft mit
noch mehr neuem Geld anzukurbeln
versuchen was ja eigentlich die Wurzel
des Problems ist
auf den ersten Blick scheint dieses
Problem nur die USA zu betreffen
da aber so viele Länder ihre Rücklagen
in Form von US-Anleihen Lagern könnte
ein Vertrauensverlust des Dollars eine
globale Krise auslösen die sämtliche
Länder der Erde betreffen würde
eine Hyperinflation des Dollars hätte
weitreichende Folgen die Auswirkungen
einer Hyperinflation lassen sich in
Ländern wie es in Wabbel beobachten was
passiert aber wenn die globale
Leitwährung Hyperinflation erfährt das
hatten wir noch nicht und die Folgen
sind unmöglich vorherzusagen die
logische Folge einer Hyperinflation des
Donners deren massive wirtschaftliche
Probleme für alle anderen Währungen der
Welt da die Reserven all dieser
Währungen letztlich in Dollar liegen
[Musik]
seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges
sind dutzende Währungen untergegangen
und die Ursache war immer die gleiche
schlechte politische Entscheidungen
aktuell treffen die USA schlechte
politische Entscheidungen und die
Zentralbank verwaltet die Währung auch
nicht gut der Untergang des Dollars ist
somit unausweichlich wir sind auf dem
Weg zum Friedhof der fiatwährungen
[Musik]
der Markt die Privatwirtschaft die
Menschen werden plötzlich verstehen was
los ist dann beginnt der Herdentrieb das
kann über Nacht passieren
wann ist passiert ist für uns nahezu
unmöglich vorherzusagen aber es besteht
immer das Risiko dass wir eines morgens
aufwachen und uns in einer gänzlich
anderen Welt wiederfinden
vielleicht nicht über eine Nacht sondern
eine Woche oder eine Monat aber wenn es
so weit ist wird es schnell gehen ohne
dass wir es vorhersehen können
Inflation ist nur eines der Szenarien
die die Welt heute bedrohen die
Geschichte lehrt uns jedoch dass jede
Nation die ihre Wirtschaft auf ein
künstliches fiat-system stützt das
gleiche Schicksal Erhalt
die Quote der Fehlschläge liegt
nachweislich bei 100%. Fiat Währungen
scheitern immer
vor 40 Jahren begann dann das große
Experiment bei dem alle Währungen mit
dem Ende des britenwood-systems
gleichzeitig zu viertwährungen wurden
die Welt muss an den Ausweg aus diesem
Dollar basierten Währungssystem finden
eine Währung braucht eine Basis man kann
sie nicht auf nichts Stützen ich
vergleiche es immer mit dem alten ersten
Superman-Film in dem Louis Lane vom
Hochhaus stürzte
ihn sicher nicht Superman und selbst
kann der Dollar nicht fliegen es war
einmal Gold dass den Dollar stützte aber
jetzt hat jeder sein Schiff an die
Titanic der Währungen gebunden und alle
werden gemeinsam untergehen
wenn das Vertrauen in den US-Dollar
schwindet was wahrscheinlich noch vor
2020 passieren wird wäre das nicht das
erste Mal in der Geschichte
dann müssten wir zu etwas zurückkehren
das Vertrauen schafft und Gold schafft
Vertrauen
die einzige Lösung ist die Rückkehr zu
einer echten gesunden Währung echtes
Geld mit echtem Gegenwert es muss nicht
Gold oder Silber sein aber in der
Vergangenheit kamen Gesellschaften durch
Versuch und Irrtum allen Experimenten
zum Trotz immer wieder zu Gold und
Silber zurück er scheint also nicht die
schlechteste Idee zu sein
Anbetracht all der Unsicherheiten der
heutigen Welt erscheint eine Rückkehr zu
einer Wirtschaft auf Basis von Gold nur
logisch warum also wird über eine
derartige Rückkehr noch nicht einmal
diskutiert die Antwort ist so einfach
wie alarmierend diejenigen die an der
Spitze sitzen und vom ponsi-system
profitieren wollen nicht dass es endet
viele glauben nun der Goldpreis würde
unterdrückt um es als globales Austausch
Medium weniger attraktiv zu machen
Regierungen versuchen den Goldpreis
niedrig zu halten damit der Dollar als
angemessene Leitwährung für die Welt
wahrgenommen wird
der Dollar hat diesen Status aber
überhaupt nicht verdient da die USA in
so schlecht verwalten
wie das Gold Andy Trust Action Comedy
kurz Gata verfolgen die in ihren Augen
gezielte Unterdrückung des Preises von
Gold und Silber durch zweifelhafte
Methoden
[Musik]
wir haben 12 Jahre lang Beweise für die
Manipulation des Goldpreises gesammelt
bei einem Mordfall würde die Jury ohne
jeden Zweifel auf schuldig plädieren
aber wir müssen alle Beweise und ihre
Zusammenhänge immer wieder erklären
der Goldpreis wird auf viele ab
manipuliert nicht alle sind einfach
nachzuweisen viele die Verkäufe durch
Zentralbanken sind jedoch klar
verzeichnet
zwischen 1999 und 2002 verkaufte die
britische Zentralbank törichterweise
einen gewaltigen Teil der britischen
Goldreserven für durchschnittlich 275
Dollar pro Unze der Erlös wurde in Euro
und Dollar investiert auch die
Regierungen von Kanada Frankreich der
Schweiz und anderen Staaten verkauften
zu der Zeit in Gold
wir wissen dass die Zentralbanken 400
Tonnen Gold pro Jahr verkauften
warum es war die mit Abstand dümmste
Entscheidung des Jahrzehnts und sie
taten es wieder und wieder heute kostet
Gold 300 bis 1600 fast 1700
warum habt ihr es also verkauft um den
Preis zu drücken es war koordiniert
damit alle weiterhin den Währungen
vertrauen
gestand vor dem Kongress dass sie den
Goldpreis manipulierten als er sagte die
Zentralbanken wären bereit Gold in
wachsenden Mengen zu leihen sollte der
Preis steigen sie taten
sollte der Goldpreis steigen bedeutet
die Unterdrückung war das Ziel die Taten
ist also schon und der gestand ist dem
Kongress gegenüber
Zentralbanken können die Goldreserven
ihrer Nationen natürlich legal veräußern
doch nutzten sie zur Unterdrückung des
Goldpreises auch dubiosere Praktiken
einige Ermittler behaupten westliche
Zentralbanken hätten ihre Goldreserven
an goldbanken verliehen
goldbanken verkaufen Gold mit dem Ziel
es später zu einem günstigeren Preis
zurückzukaufen
der
Vergangenheit auch in us-bundesanleihen
das ist Ansicht zwar kein Problem doch
verzeichnen die Zentralbanken ihr
eigenes Gold und das Gold dass sie den
goldbanken geliehen haben als einen
Posten so kann eine Zentralbank zwar
behaupten sie hätte Goldreserven in
einer gewissen Höhe doch ein Großteil
davon kann an goldbanken verliehen sein
die dieses Gold womöglich gegen
Bundesanleihen verkauft haben
eine Möglichkeit der Intervention auf
dem Goldmarkt ist das Verleihen von Gold
an sogenannte goldbanken die das Gold
dann auf dem Markt verkaufen das
unterdrückt den Preis ebenso wie direkte
Verkäufe der Zentralbanken taucht aber
nicht in ihren Büchern auf
ein paar Jahren endete die
us-staatskasse wie Gold verzeichnet wird
so dass nun einige Forderungen ebenso
wie der Goldbestand gemeinsam aufgeführt
werden
sie verbuchen also das was sie
tatsächlich haben und das was ihnen
geschuldet wird
ein und das selbe was betrügerische
Buchführung gleich kommt
doch wozu all der Aufwand zur
Unterdrückung des Gold- und
Silberpreises warum bedrohen faire Gold
und Silberpreise das ponsi-system
Gold und nationale Währungen stehen in
Konkurrenz zueinander denn Gold ist der
einzige Konkurrent nationaler Währungen
Gold ist Geld und die Währungen sind
Geld Ersatz der Stadt Gold zirkuliert
bei vier Währungen hat die Regierung die
Macht bei echten Geld die Bevölkerung
echtes Geld beschränkt die Regierung
denn sie kann nur ihre Steuereinnahmen
ausgeben die Bevölkerung sträubt sich
gegen steuern aber wenn die Regierung
einfach Geld leihen und drucken kann
fällt der Widerstand Weg die Regierung
kann einfach erwachsen wenn sie einem
etwas im Austausch für nichts verspricht
und genau das tun sie Gold schützt die
Menschen vor unverantwortlichen
Regierungen Gold beschränkt Regierungen
denn die würden gerne tun was sie wollen
doch gold steht ihnen im Weg Gold ist
der Feind übergriffiger Regierungen aber
ein Freund der Freiheit ein Schutz des
Einzelnen vor der Regierung
mit dem Dollar ein hoher Preis bedroht
die Inflation es ist ein Barometer für
die US-Wirtschaft aktuell auf Höhenflug
während die Welt zusammenbricht es zeigt
uns wie schlimm die Lage ist also wollen
die Wall Street und die Regierung mit
ihren Politikern den Preis unterdrücken
die Wall Street will nicht dass du zum
Münzkontor gehst und Gold und
Silbermünzen kaufst sie wollen dir
Papiere andrehen die Regierung genauso
zusammen mit der Wallstreet
Gold im Besitz des Volkes ist die
Kontrolle der Regierung die Regierung
kann kein Geld erschaffen wenn es Gold
ist sie erschafft nur Papiergeld aus dem
Nichts mit diesem Papiergeld können Sie
dann Kriege führen oder ist als
politisches Mittel zum Zweck nutzen um
ihre Freunde zu bereichern also kämpfen
Regierungen schon das ganze Jahrhundert
lang gegen Gold an
trotz all dieser Bemühungen den Preis
von Gold und Silber niedrig zu halten
stieg die Nachfrage nach Gold und Silber
aufgrund der Instabilität des Marktes
zuletzt drastisch was ein tiefer
greifendes Problem der Zentralbanken
offenbarte
westliche Zentralbanken haben nun das
Problem dass sie viel Gold verkauft
haben um den Goldpreis zu unterdrücken
sie werden jetzt von Banken außerhalb
dieses ursprünglichen Kartells
vorgeführt die mit großem Eifer Gold
aufkaufen
diese ganzen kleineren Zentralbanken
abseits des Mainstreams die nicht Teil
der Elite des internationalen
Bankenwesen sind sichern sich jetzt
hunderte Tonnen davon
den Goldpreis zu unterdrücken mussten
westliche Zentralbanken die nationalen
Goldreserven verkaufen oder verleihen da
das Gold dabei jedoch ihre tresorin nur
selten verlässt weiß niemand ob sie
nicht mehr Gold verkaufen oder verleihen
als sie tatsächlich haben
sollte dem so sein wäre es eine der
größten Betrugsmaschen der
Weltgeschichte ein gewaltiger Schwindel
doch nicht von einzelnen ausgehen
sondern von ganzen Regierungen
das centralbank das meiste Gold der
Zentralbanken liegt in der Federal
Reserve in New York und der Bank of
England bleibt also in ihren Kellern bei
internationalen Verkäufen verschieben
Sie nur ein paar Barren von einem Haufen
auf den nächsten machen ein anderes
Etikett daran oder verändern nur einen
Registereintrag
da sind allerdings recht kreative
Registereinträge dabei und ich glaube
nicht dass tatsächlich alles von dem
Gold vorhanden ist
das Problem bleibt bestehen wenn alle
besonders die großen Fische ihr Gold
gleichzeitig geliefert haben wollten
wäre das einfach nicht möglich
beim meisten Geld ist es so dass jede
Unsinn mehrfach verkauft wurde und
mehrere Personen meinen es würde ihnen
gehören
ich sage es immer wieder wenn man es
nicht in die Hand nehmen kann gehört es
einem nicht
das Spiel muss früher oder später enden
irgendwann wird das physische Gold und
Silber eingefordert wir sehen das auch
heute schon
der Mangel an Verantwortlichkeit bei
goldverkäufen westlicher Zentralbanken
hat bisher kaum besorgniserregt wenn
jedoch mehr und mehr Goldkäufer
physische Lieferungen verlangen werden
die Zentralbanken die zu viel verkauft
oder ihre nationalen Goldreserven
verliehen haben einen gewaltigen Skandal
auslösen
infolge derartiger Betrügereien könnten
Goldkäufer ob Einzelpersonen pensions-
oder Hedgefonds oder sogar ganze
Nationen um Milliarden Dollar betrogen
werden
er erinnert ein wenig an den
murdox-skandal bei Fox in London und den
mädelskandal die Presse ist mit den
Superreichen und der Politik ins Bett
gegangen leider ändert sich immer erst
etwas wenn die Bombe geplatzt ist
hoch Gold wird ebenso hochgehen mehr
noch als diese beiden da es weltweit das
Finanzwesen betrifft
[Musik]
die Politiker und Banker von heute haben
alles verlernt außer mehr Geld zu
drucken und die Währung aufzublasen
das ist ihr ganzes Repertoire wenn wir
uns weiterhin auf sie und ihre Führung
bei der Lösung von Problemen verlassen
wie könnten wir etwas anderes erwarten
Sie können nichts anderes
die einzige andere Möglichkeit wäre die
Inflation zu beenden und zu einer
gesunden Währung zurückzukehren aber das
wollen sie nicht denn dann wären sie
arbeitslos
obwohl sich Risse im Finanzsystem auftun
sind die einzigen Lösungsvorschläge der
Regierungen diejenigen die uns der
Katastrophe immer näher bringen
die Welt nicht selbst retten doch kann
man Schritte ergreifen um zumindest sich
und seine Familie zu schützen
man kann nicht von einem ponsi-betrüger
verlangen dass er ein ehrliches Geschäft
führt
das kann er nicht
man kann also nicht von den ganzen
ponsi-betrügern der Regierung verlangen
dass sie die Krise auf andere Art und
Weise lösen sollen sie wissen ja nicht
wie das geht
wir müssen aufhören uns für die Lösung
unserer Probleme auf die gleichen
Menschen mit der gleichen Mentalität zu
verlassen
wenn die Regierung nicht zum
Goldstandard zurückkehren wollen müssen
die Bürger das selbst tun
regierungen können so viel Fiat Geld
erschaffen wie Sie wollen dafür ist es
da warum sollte man dem also Vertrauen
den Politikern den Bürokraten und
Zentralbankern wenn man etwas Echtes
haben kann etwas mit intrinsischen wert
das weiterhin selten bleiben wird
Gold oder Fiat Geld wir beobachten
überall auf der Welt wie die Menschen
erkennen dass Gold seinen Wert mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit viel besser bewahrt
als ein Stück Papier
es geht nicht darum dass der Goldpreis
steigt sondern dass der Wert des Dollars
sinkt die menschliche Anstrengung und
Kaufkraft bei Gold bleibt gleich mit
einer Unze kann man heute noch genauso
viel kaufen wie vor 2000 Jahren die
Gewinnung einer Unze Gold verschlingt
heute noch genauso viel menschliche
Anstrengung wie vor 2000 Jahren durch
diese aufwandsgleichheit bei der
Gewinnung ist Gold zu stabil
Gold ist finanzielle Absicherung
beim Goldbesitz geht es darum dass man
sich schützen will
man muss es haben schon alleine um ruhig
schlafen zu können
sonst bleibt einem nichts bei
Katastrophen wie wir sie schon oft
erlebt haben
wie schützt man sich sonst
das aktuelle Finanzsystem mag untergehen
doch jedes Chaos bietet auch Chancen
der Zusammenbruch des alten Systems
könnte die Tür zu großem Wohlstand
aufstoßen
es ist sicher nicht das Ende der Welt
vielleicht noch nicht mal von Amerika
für viele Länder wird es dem Beginn
eines Aufschwungs markieren da eine
gewaltige Last von ihnen genommen wird
die Welt wird nicht länger Billionen an
Amerika sein müssen damit wir hier
verbrauchen können ohne zu produzieren
diese Untergang wird der Welt gut tun
wir sollten ihn als Weltgemeinschaft
nicht fürchten sondern begrüßen
es wird die größte wohlstandsverlagerung
der Geschichte sein die globale
Währungskrise wird eine größere
Verlagerung von Wohlstand verursachen
als wir sie in der Geschichte beobachten
könnten und zwar plötzlich also ist es
auch die größte Chance
was ist Geld was sollte es sein und sie
machen große Fortschritte dabei
besonders die junge Generation
[Musik]
auch morgen geht die Sonne auf wie schon
millionenfach zuvor Pendler wachen auf
und fahren ins Büro um ihr Tagewerk zu
verrichten
Landwirte kümmern sich um die Ernte und
Bauarbeiter errichten neue Infrastruktur
doch wird die Welt noch dieselbe sein
2008 der alte die Welt ein weghof der
größte Finanzcrash der Weltgeschichte
wurde durch die gleichen schlechten
Entscheidungen verzögert die ihn
verursacht hatten die gewaltige
Bankenrettung erkaufte uns keine Lösung
nur Zeit Zeit in der die
Verantwortlichen einem sterbenden System
die letzten Dollar abrangen
aber gleichzeitig erhielten diejenigen
die den Abgrund kommen sollen die
Gelegenheit sich selbst und ihre
Familien vor dem bevorstehenden Fall zu
schützen diese Zeit könnte sich als das
wertvollste aller Güter erweisen
[Musik]
es gibt in der Geschichte immer wieder
diese kurzen Momente in denen die
absicherungswährung der vergangenen 5000
Jahre zeitgleich die Wertanlage mit der
größten potenziellen Wachstumschance in
Sachen Kaufkraft ist
so etwas erleben wir gerade Geld ist die
beste Wertanlage
[Gelächter]
man stößt Währung ab kauft Geld und kann
sich später wahrscheinlich sehr viel
mehr davon kaufen
am besten wäre es jedoch wenn die
Menschen Verantwortung übernehmen und
sich in Sachen Finanzen informieren
würden
das Wichtigste ist sich nicht mehr bei
allen Entscheidungen von den Banken
Brokern und anderen Leuten leiten zu
lassen und sich für sich selbst stark zu
machen
[Musik]